i've been chasing their boss forever
this might go south
hell of a day isn't it partner
[Music]
[Applause]
up here
go go go
[Music]
you better go [ __ ] don't you touch my
baby
come on big boy come on pig boy
you all need to leave
please
who are you i'm a cop these two just
shot my partner down the road
run
i need you to get to safety these people
will kill you this is my farm they don't
belong here
who are these guys they're drug dealers
scumbags you're my prisoner until my
boss gets here i'm finishing this alone
i will defend this land
this is certainly a development
we came here to kill or did any of you
not get the memo on that
because evidently this cop did
i expect you and i aren't so different
nothing like you i got shot today and
i'm tied up
and you still hit like a [ __ ]
you need my help that's the house that i
shared with my wife
that is all i've got left all right
let's go save them
i got your back
we killed
or be killed
run i gotta finish this
run or a rest wrong place wrong time i'm
gonna be the guy that's gonna kill you
i'm not going anywhere
this is my farm
[Music]
you